ok let's look at more heavy duty stuff
appstats appstats is a function that
allows you to get extensive information
on how API functions are called by your
application this is used to profile your
application you do this by inspect the
API calls made by your application to
for example datastore and memcache and
then you can use the information to
optimize your application for example
you can find opportunities to minimize
latency by caching data it can also be
used to reduce or bundle API calls AB
stats can also help you reduce costs if
you go beyond the free tier as it can
display the cost associated with
different API calls so let's see how you
can use app stats well first of all you
can enable the API tracing through
configuration so there is no need to
make any modifications to your
application and when you have run your
application it is possible to access the
profiling information using a URL you
can see how to do both of those things
in the instructor notes so let's look at
the information that app stats will
provide you with first of all app stats
has a dashboard screen where you will
see all the different data available so
let's look at each section separately
the RPC stats table shows statistics
information for each remote procedure
call made by your application so here
you can see for example data store get
operations you can see the number of
calls the cost for the calls and the
percentage cost for the calls this page
also displays other calls for example
memcache get or data store run query
that's the RPC stats table very useful
information the path stats table shows
similar information but it is grouped
from the perspective of your code
instead so here you can see that our
query conference makes calls to data
store get and data store run query the
requests history table shows information
about a specific request that was made
here for example query conferences was
executed at this time and made call to
these api functions this table also has
statistics for register for conference
and get profile the RPC time line graph
shows when specific RPC calls were made
and how long the request took the
process so here you can see that get-go
auth user took 6 milliseconds followed
by data to begin transaction 4
milliseconds then to get
operations towards data store followed
by a put operation and then finally the
transaction commits so this graph shows
you the sequence of API calls and how
long each took to execute and of course
you can also see your complete request
latency that's appstats a great way to
understand your application behavior and
optimize it